the israeli bombardment of gaza is now
into its second week and despite the
days of international condemnation
the calls for a cease-fire had no impact
let's have a look at gaza a little bit
earlier right uh when airstrikes hit the
palestinian enclave all morning in fact
with a renewed intensity this was a
factory inside a refugee camp which was
hit israel says it is targeting tunnels
military facilities and residences used
by palestinian factions
all told 198 palestinians including 58
children have been killed
here is our team to bring us up to date
with everything harry falson on the
left-hand side of your screen occupied
east jerusalem nida ibrahim in ramallah
in the occupied west bank we'll be with
you too shortly first yum the al-sayed
who's outside the besieged enclaves main
hospital
and tell us what about about what you've
been seeing there today yumna
hello until now uh was i mean it's
another tense day in the bombardment on
the gaza strip uh just in the early
hours of this day the the air raids were
very heavy the artillery shells were
were very violently uh targeting
different areas of the gaza strip mainly
in the west and the east
on my way i myself on my way here to
shifa complex early in the morning uh
there was a car that was targeted just
10 meters away from
my car
and without prior notice uh there were
four people in the car three of them
came out in pieces
and one severely severely wounded
later after that a couple of houses have
been targeted and have arrived as like
bodies more bodies have arrived to a
shiva complex
we were talking i was talking to the
doctors here and they said that the
morgues are full already the hospital is
running out of resources and running out
of medical requirements and supplies
the corridors
have have been stuffed with beds to take
more uh patients uh of those who are uh
severely wounded or uh or are in diff in
difficult conditions right and the whole
strip is well you have no running out of
the basics fuel and water
the the
power outages are huge in the strip i
mean uh the
electricity comes from one hour to three
hours at best uh in in in different
times and and that's that's uh a crisis
for the hospitals that are running and
the generators are running out of fuel
so there is a great shortage in
electricity and of course when we say
there is shortage in electricity in gaza
then there is
automatically a shortage in water as
well because there is no electricity to
generate the water
so that we can get water supply so now
uh gaza is going through the crisis of
great shortage
in power uh due to all the destruction
in the lines of the electricity lines
and the power and the even the company
the power distribution company
has been partly also uh damaged and
almost all the infrastructure uh the
cables have been damaged in in in almost
all the areas of the gaza strip so now
we're we're going through not only uh or
the gaza strip is going through not only
a an adequate shortage of fuel and power
shortages and outages and water lack of
water but also uh the medical uh sector
is is is like uh
extensively being threatened now with
the amount of shortages in medical
supplies and requirements okay you're
not excited i'll leave you there i want
to get to our other correspondents and
our guests as well thank you for now
before we go to nida uh the prime
minister of the palestinian authorities
spoke earlier today in ramallah
party calling for a general strike
across the occupied west bank on tuesday
in his speech he thanked members of the
international community for condemning
the killings in gaza but said more must
be done
the united nations must
issue a resolution
that describes all these
actions as illegal
and illegitimate against our palestinian
people sanctions and punishment must be
there against israel our friendly
countries must summon up their
ambassadors in israel
as a representation and a sign
of
rejecting
this
in addition to what we heard from the
prime minister i believe you've got news
on the u.s envoy
yes the u.s depart deputy secretary for
israeli and palestinian affairs has
arrived in ramallah and has met with
three palestinian officials according to
a statement by the palestinian civil
affairs ministry he met with the
palestinian president's adviser for
diplomatic affairs as well as the
palestinian head of intelligence and the
palestinian minister of civil affairs
and in the statement released by the
palestinians they said that they urged
the u.s administration to pressure
israel to stop what the palestinians
called the assault against the
palestinians and they said that the
right-wing israeli government as well as
the continued settler attack are killing
any opportunity or any hope for a future
settlement or negotiations between the
palestinians and israelis so this is the
latest from mahadayama
the the u.s envoy who has been in tel
aviv for the past few days and we've
heard from other sources telling us that
he is going to be meeting with the
palestinian president mahmoud abbas
other reports are saying that he's
indeed now with the meeting with
president mahmoud abbas the palestinian
authority says it's still invested in
diplomatic efforts for the escalation
they say that they want the u.s and the
world countries to
intervene and pressure israel to end its
occupation as well as what they call the
latest aggression on the palestinians
specifically in the besieged gaza strip
this is not something that many
palestinians are appreciating they're
saying that the palestinian authority
needs to do more and that they're taking
a soft approach when it comes to the
situation in the occupied territory okay
thank you nida ibrahim reporting from
ramallah in the occupied west bank now
on to uh the mount of olives in fact
occupied east jerusalem and here is
harry force at harry what updates can
you bring us from there today
well yes here in occupied east jerusalem
there have been another round well over
the last 24 hours or so
rounds of arrests going on this is in
the light of what the israeli prime
minister benjamin netanyahu has tried to
be
instituting in the security forces in
the police a much tougher response he
says
to the kind of violence that we've been
seeing both here in occupied east
jerusalem and inside israel
the majority of those arrests appearing
to be of palestinians and as well as
that in the last 24 hours less than that
we've seen
the most violent incidents so far
in weeks of protests in and around the
neighborhood of shakespeare where there
are four palestinian families under
imminent threat of forced expulsion it
has been a factor of fueling and driving
a lot of the protests which erupted in
violence and then went so much further
afield from there but a very violent
incident there and the images at the top
of our report on that some people may
well find distressing
uh actually harry we haven't got your
report this hour i'm sorry we will play
it again later on but i have got a guest
from uh um coming up sorry about that
apologies though that's quite all right
harry fawcett in occupation thank you
for that
now this is important israel is warning
that the united awards warned the united
nations that it plans to bomb two
schools on the gaza strip and it is
understood that these schools also act
as accommodation for refugees we have
mathias ishmael with us now who is the
director general of unrwa which is the
united nations humanitarian aid agency
for palestinian refugees mr schmel thank
you for your time first of all i know
you'll be incredibly busy do you know
more about this the warnings from israel
over your schools
yeah good afternoon to you i have
frankly not been directly informed of
this
so far the message from the israeli side
has been that installations that are
colored in blue and have a un flag like
the one i'm in are protected so i am
trying to check this out i have not been
given this direct warning right it must
be a huge concern for you though even if
you just think about what happened to
the media building the other day which
was destroyed which housed the ap and al
jazeera
the israelis took the view that there
was hamas elements there and bombed it
anyway would you be concerned that they
would take the same
view of of un facilities
absolutely i mean we need to be clear we
are in war here this is a war like 2014
and in many ways at a more violent level
the the price the civilian population is
paying for this is increasingly high you
know any civilian death is unacceptable
we now have more than 50 children dead
and killed among them 18 children that
went to our umrah schools
that for me is just an unacceptable
price that the civilian population is
paying and indeed we have seen several
buildings taken down in which civilians
lived and so yes in most cases they were
warned to evacuate those buildings but
we now have i believe at latest count at
least 5 000 people without a home so
that's a second price they're paying and
then the third one is we are here in one
of our installations people are scared
they are terrified this is experienced
as terror from the skies and people are
increasingly leaving their homes we now
have more than 41 000 people in 50
schools and to come back to your
question it would be of grave concern if
any of these installations were directly
how are you able or are you able to look
after all of those thousands of people
because we were reporting earlier about
shortages of water and fuel now
so the priority we are into the third
day of having people in our
installations like this the priority so
far has been to make them safe and what
that means is number one that there are
no unexploded devices lying around
number two we are still in covet times
we've had to make sure that we have
protective
equipment ppe for them and now we have
been starting to look since yesterday at
what to do in terms of basic needs like
water we have half of our installations
kitted out for a situation like this
with solar energy and water supplies and
sanitary facilities but half are not and
we are racing against time now to try
and meet these basic needs obviously we
will have to have the border open at
some point to bring in supplies for the
moment we are okay but as you have said
throughout this session um there will be
critical supply needs in the next few
days
i think um mr shmael i can hear the
noise of maybe a drone actually above
you a sort of a buzzing noise around
there it makes me think about the
conversations that you have with the
israelis i'm sure that you give them the
exact coordinates for your facilities so
that they don't get bombed how did those
conversations actually go
i mean we have a long established
process i think every six months we
update them on all our installations so
they have those coordinates i must say
during this current war the
conversations have been difficult my
understanding i wasn't here but in 2014
we much more early on had humanitarian
corridors you know where there was a
lull in the fighting and we could move
to installations bring material and so
on so far in day seven or eight of this
they have not granted that they've also
not granted us to bring in and out
people you know so it's it's at the
moment it's very difficult conversations
a big important part also is that they
are hitting striking very close to our
installations my main office complex is
severely damaged in parts of it because
the strikes were very close to it and so
an understanding we had in the past that
they would also be
and keep some distance in their striking
from our installations is just not being
respected sufficiently okay mathias
schmale director general of anwar thank
you for taking the time for us today i
know you'll be very busy we really
appreciate it
thank you very much for this opportunity
i